in other world news the United States is
halting some flights to Philadelphia and
delaying others to New York because of a
thick layer of smoke coming from
Canadian wildfires thousands of
passengers have been stranded air
quality levels and alerts have been
issued in 15 U.S states because of the
smoke from the wildfires the governor of
New York is making n95 masks available
to Residents it now ranks among the 10
cities with the worst air quality
worldwide let's show you some live
pictures right now on the left hand side
of your screen is Philadelphia the
airport there as you can see a thick
layer of smoke in the skies there and on
the right just a few minutes ago you
could just make about make out the
Empire State Building in New York and
now it's barely visible so as you can
see the conditions clearly very bad in
both New York and Philadelphia let's see
what's happening in Washington DC where
Alan Fisher is what's it like in the U.S
Capitol Allen
morning on my commute to work now
normally if you look down there you
could see the Capitol building but
because of the Milky Sky which is caused
by the air pollution you can probably
just about make out the outline and
remember when everyone said it was okay
not to wear a mask outside while so many
more people are wearing masks today
simply because of the air pollution now
normally air pollution is measured on a
scale from zero to more than 300 if
you're under 50 you're doing okay 200 is
considered very unhealthy at the moment
in Washington DC at Freedom Plaza the
reading is
317 so you can understand just how
unhealthy that is particularly for
people with respiratory diseases but for
everyone else as well incredibly there's
still people out running and
skateboarding here but a lot of people
are staying at home and that includes
federal workers now a number of shows in
in New York last night were canceled
that's going to be a similar story as
this moves down the East Coast New York
has it bad yesterday today is going to
be the turn of Philadelphia of Baltimore
and of Washington DC to really bear the
brunt of this and it's expected to drag
on into the weekend now you know I could
turn around here and show you over there
that's normally where you could see the
Washington Monument but as you can
really see it's not around at the moment
simply because of the haze and the sky
people are coughing people are being
worried about uh what is happening here
but of course the United States has
promised that it's going to help the
Canadians deal with the fires they're
sending 600 firefighters and support
staff up into Canada to help the battle
there yeah and Alan the FAA has passed
flights from the Northeast uh heading
into Philadelphia and some also to New
York this is going to cause a huge
disruption obviously
that's right there was a ground stop at
LaGuardia in New York in the last few
hours that has now been lifted what
they're operating on are now delays and
they're saying that the average delay is
going to be somewhere in the region of
35 minutes that could slip but it could
get as much as 57 minutes so you're
talking about at least an hour and there
have been a number of cancellations
simply because those flights aren't able
to take off at the moment and that is
going to screw up the the schedule
elsewhere as well so for everyone here
in Washington and across the East Coast
it really is pretty bad I can feel it
even just in the little time I've been
talking catching on the back of my
throat and for others who who must be
worried about their health this must be
a fairly troubling time particularly as
they now have to dig out the masks that
we thought we'd cast aside after covered
and find out that they could be put to
pretty good use over the next few days
yeah I bet you a lot of people are going
to be wearing those masks thank you Alan
for the update there from Washington DC
Alan Fisher while tens of millions of
people in Canada are also being told to
stay indoors because of smoke from the
wildfires more than 400 are burning
authorities say this is one of his worst
fire seasons on record let's speak to
Keith Stewart who is a senior energy
strategist at Greenpeace Canada is
joining us from Toronto Keith thank you
so much for being with us an
unprecedented situation really in Canada
the worst start to the the world
Wildfire season uh ever recorded can you
tell us first what it's like in Toronto
where you are we've seen how it's in the
U.S right now in Philadelphia in
Washington DC and New York what's it
like in Toronto how bad is it
so it's bad now and it's going to get a
lot worse according to the sort of
modeling that they're doing
um I had to tell my daughter why she
left for school this morning wearing a
mask to you know remember don't breathe
deeply if you can avoid it their
school's not going to allow them to go
outside
um it's uh you know people are cutting
back normally I'd be biking to work
right now I'm just going to work from
home because
the exercise would not be worth the
damage to my lungs it's you know it's
bad
um and I think it's it's been
interesting watching the response from
politicians here in Canada because this
really is unprecedented we never get
this many wildfires this early you know
even in August we don't normally get it
this bad and one of the challenges we're
facing is you know 600 firefighters come
from the US that's great because
normally we move firefighters around in
Canada it's like when the fires are in
the west we send the people from the
East and vice versa but now they're
everywhere at once Keith why why are
these wildfires more intense than in
previous years what what are the
contributing factors
so the big factor here is climate change
uh as the temperatures get hotter the
air gets drier we've already seen over
the you know this is no longer a future
problem this is happening now the
Wildfire seasons are getting longer
um but also you does the conditions when
the sort of the dryness is key and I
think we've had that dryness right
across the country so you know a little
spark or a bit of lightning that might
have smoldered for a bit and gone out if
the ground is wet is just taking off and
this is the kind of thing we're
expecting to see more of um our federal
government is now actually pondering
setting up a national agency to deal
with this because the old systems aren't
working and the real problem here is you
know if we if if I want to be able to
send my kid to school without a mask we
need to stop burning fossil fuels
because it's that the burning of fossil
fuels fueling climate change that is
causing this problem to get so much
worse yeah I was going to ask you about
that next I mean scientists have warned
that these extreme weather fuel
disasters will continue and become more
common and more destructive what
measures are needed right now to address
this situation and what can be done to
prevent these wildfires going forward
so there's really three things we can do
about climate change number one we can
try and reduce emissions of uh
greenhouse gases by burning fewer fossil
fuels and in Canada we're starting to
make some inroads in that direction
support for electric transportation uh
you know there's some grants now to help
get Combs off of heating oil and onto
electric heating and cooling
but you know our big problem here is our
fossil fuel industry is our major export
oil is our biggest export and they are
incredibly political powerful and
they're fighting action on this every
step of the way but we need to get off
the fossil fuels as quickly as possible
but we also need to adapt to those
changes that we we can't avoid and
that's we need better Disaster Response
management we need better systems to
deal with these types of crises because
the problem is when you keep getting hit
by crisis after crisis if you haven't
recovered from the last one you can't
prepare for the next one and we need to
get ahead of that curve because that's
called adaptation we can try and
mitigate by reducing greenhouse gas
emissions adapt to those changes we
can't avoid but then the third option is
simply to suffer and the less we do to
you know get off of fossil fuels to
prepare our communities for a warmer
world the more people are going to
suffer and right now you know watching
people whose homes homes are literally
being burned right
um people fleeing flyers in their cars
this is terrifying and and it's
something that we should not accept as
The New Normal Keith thank you so much
for talking to us Keith Stewart from
Greenpeace joining us there from Toronto